sur le sujet de la montée de de la
violence vous comprenez bien que il
s'assoit sur la montée de la violence
dans la société bien sûr et je peux vous
dire quelles en sont l'origine d'après
moi mais est-ce que nous allons amener
quelque chose de nouveau dans ce congrès
des maires sur ce sujet non bien sûr
nous allons écouter parce que on pourra
toujours progresser sur le premier
semestre 2024 mais là l'échéance que
nous attendons c'est véritablement la
sanction dire aussi que l'on a annoncé
hier un numéro que pourront appeler nos
maères sur le champ tout simplement de
la protection psychologique moi j'ai vu
à l'issue des émeutes des mèr à qui les
larmes sont montées aux yeux et on a
échangé sur cette violence psychologique
issue de ces émeutes début juillet et
donc oui on a pensé c'est une de le
demand ce numéro euh ben oui parce que
derrière ça peut donner lieu à à un
diagnosti il peut peut-être les
encourager familialement parce que il
n'est pas uniquement destiné aux maères
aux élus mais aussi euh à leur famille
tu as quand la la l'association des mers
des France parle de commune attaqué euh
vous répondez violence faite aux élus
est-ce qu'il y a que ça c'est
essentiellement ça ou il y a d'autres
d'autres points qui sont sur la table en
quoi les communes se sentent attaquées
aujourd'hui communes attaqué euh ça
sous-entend violence faite aux élus oui
mais pas que ça veut dire aussi euh
attaque au bien de la collectivité on
l'a vu euh au au mois de au mois de
juillet et surtout faut rappeler que
dans ces 138 C fait et c'est plus 15 %
on ne va trouver que moins de 5 % et
heureusement de violence faite au Mair
et aux élus violence physique très peu
heureusement donc beaucoup d'attaques au
bien école on l'a vu hein pendant les
émettes donc quelles sont les origines
peut-être me demandiez-vous oui non mais
juste sur les attaques au bien parce que
les maires doivent payer la
reconstruction et il y a des maires qui
sont lâchés par les assurantces soit
qu'il les lâche soit qu'il leur demande
des tarifs Exor bitant est-ce que vous
avez les moyens de faire pression sur
les assureurs qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
faire nous avons lancé une mission avec
Bruno Le Maire il y a moi environ avec à
la fois deux inspecteurs mais aussi un
maire Alain chrétien et puis un
dirigeant d'une compagnie d'assurance et
c'est ce quitureur qui est en train de
travailler pour nous apporter des
solutions les compagnies d'assurance
sont confronté à des dégâts énormes et à
devoir rembourser des travaux dans des
proportions qui sont qui ne sont plus
corrélé au au risqu qu'ils ont pris et
il nous faut trouver un chemin pour
permettre à toute collectivité qui le
souhaite de vouloir s'assurer mais en
même temps ne pas amener au dépôt de
bilan nos compagnies d'assurance ce qui
aurait pu être le se désengage qui
disent que c'est plus rentable
aujourd'hui d'assurer les collectivités
exactement je prendre juste le petit
exemple de la SMAC vous savez c'est une
compagnie d'assurance une mutuelle qui
assure près de 80 % de nos communes et
elle rembourse de l'ordre de 4 millions
d'euros de dégâts par an avec les
émeutes de fin juin début juillet c'est
autour de 46 millions d'euros qu'elle
doit rembourser donc euh euh il n'y a il
si la Maïf n'était pas venue au capital
de l'macle à hauteur de 100 millions
d'euros ben laasmacle n'aurait pas pu
poursuivre et n'aurait plus ne serait
plus une mutuelle pérenne pour nos
collectivités